ja also wir haben ja seit den 60er
Jahren seit dem Konter ganz Skandal
zufriedenstellende Zulassungen für neue
Medikamente entwickelt wir haben auch
Sicherheitssystem entwickelt um
danebenwirkungen rechtzeitig zu
entdecken und diese Sicherheitssysteme
für neue Arzneimittel sind seit der
corona-krise quasi hinweggefegt worden
ja es werden Zulassungsstudien
akzeptiert die gefälscht sind die meiner
Meinung nach korrupt sind die ist gerade
Gegenteil behaupten als das was wirklich
drin steht dafür dass Medikament
zugelassen dann werden rechtlich
vorgeschriebene Sicherheitssysteme von
Paul ehrlichen Institut ignoriert ja
seit zwei Jahren werden die Vorgaben des
Infektionsschutzgesetzes mit den
krankenkassendaten die die Meldungen zu
vergleichen ignoriert die Daten sind
eindeutig ja wir haben ein riesen
Sicherheitsprobleme mit dieser Impfung
aber diejenigen die das dann auch
bekannt machen werden dann vom Bundestag
ausgelacht ich will mal so ganz klar
sagen wir werden auch Beruf Opfer von
den Parlamentariern ausgelacht und was
macht der Gesundheitsminister
rennt in Davos rum als die Verkörperung
der German Angst ja als einziger Trikot
dort eine Maske und redet dort wirres
Zeug im Sinne von jahrhundert der
Pandemien und wir haben hier ein Arznei
mittelproblem ja und ich sitze jeden Tag
Patienten gegenüber ich muss Ihnen
erklären warum sie in Zukunft neuartigen
Medikamenten nicht mehr vertrauen dürfen
weil sie Freiwild geworden sind für
profitgetriebene Interessen die
offensichtlich die Behörden der
durchseucht haben und eins müssen wir
wissen wenn wir sicherer Arzneimittel
wollen in Deutschland besonders die
Neuzulassungen dann müssen die
Verantwortlichen zur Rechenschaft
gezogen werden und Sie müssen vor
Gericht stehen und das erhoffe ich mir
von von dem nächsten Jahr dass das
passiert das war eine ganz schöne
Ansprache ich will da einmal noch in die
Tiefe gehen laut im Register lassen sich
immer noch bis zu 23.000 Menschen
täglich gegen Corona impfen welche
Gefahr und ihnen und auf welche Quellen
berufen sie sich da ja es ist einfach
fürchterlich die diese Menschen
vertrauen halt einfach immer noch der
Regierung Vertrauen auch den
wissenschaftsverbänden aber die Zahlen
sind wirklich verrückt wir sehen die
Anstiege von neuen Todesfällen da wird
immer gesagt ja das kann man nicht
beweisen dass es ursächlich damit
zusammenhängt darum geht es nicht es
geht um Warnsignale das übrigens auch
ein Phänomen der amerikanischen CDC da
hat wurde gerade aufgedeckt dass die CDC
das was sie als nationale
Sicherheitssystem macht das ist
vergleichbar mit der Zulassungsbehörde
in Deutschland dass die diese schlagen
zahlen einfach unterschlagen haben es
ist es ist ein Riesenskandal man lässt
die Leute ins offene messerinnen ich
habe wirklich fast täglich Probleme ja
das ist ein ganz typische Beschwerden
nach der Impfung geht's los mit
kribbelnden komischen Hautproblemen
manchmal geht die Kraft Weg das kann zu
weit gehen dass die Leute im Rollstuhl
sitzen sie haben Herzrhythmusstörungen
sie haben brustdruck sie rennen in die
Notaufnahme werden abgewimmelt dann
heißt longi das ist nicht nur Kurve die
Physiologie des emmera Impfstoff ist
ganz klar das von Anfang an klar dass es
ein Hochrisiko Medikament ist und das
sehen wir jetzt einfach und es wird
einfach
ignoriert in die Leute werden weiter ans
Messer geliefert das ist ein
Riesenskandal und der muss aufgearbeitet
werden weil ich will wieder sichere
Medikamente haben ich will wieder in
einer Medizin arbeiten die Verantwortung
trägt und so geht es gerade nicht weiter
ehrlich nicht der Platz sie haben im
Bundestag für die Impfpflicht gestimmt
wenn sie jetzt Herrn Dr Frank sprechen
also das habe ich nicht weil wir hatten
ja mal wir hatten ja die nee wir hatten
ja die Debatte aber es gab am Ende ja
keine Abstimmung bzw es gab keinen
Antrag der durchgekommen ist
ich war nicht dafür ich habe damals
gesagt wenn wir sicherstellen können
dass wir mit einer Impfpflicht dafür
sorgen dass es keine lockdowns mehr gibt
und die Kollateralschäden die wir damals
erlebt haben verändert werden dann kann
man in der Abwägung für eine Impfpflicht
sein aber das natürlich auch eine
Debatte die jetzt heute gar nicht mehr
aktuell ist was ich
aber schon für sehr wichtig finde und da
will ich auch wirklich klar
widersprechen weil das nach meinem
Kenntnisstand eigentlich alle
Wissenschaftler auch weltweit
übereinstimmt sagen dass natürlich
alle Wissenschaften
Gynäkologen und Philologen auch also
nehmen sie alle Wissenschaft also nehmen
sie mal nehmen Sie mal Beispiel und
virol dich sehr schätze den Hendrik der
ja selber auch gesagt hat so man muss
immer auch alles im Blick haben man darf
das nicht nur rein virologisch
betrachten sondern muss immer auch
abwägen aber auch der sagt natürlich ist
es sinnvoll sich impfen zu lassen
genauso wie andere Virologen oder andere
Wissenschaftler so und wir sehen
so jetzt nehmen wir machen wir mal den
Lackmustest schauen wir mal nach China
die Chinesen haben das ja nicht
besonders gut hinbekommen dass die
Bevölkerung durchgeimpft ist so und da
sterben jeden Tag im Moment tausende
Menschen oder sehr sehr viele Menschen
weil die Menschen nicht geimpft sind
oder ein ganz schlechten Impfstoff haben
und in den Ländern wurde sehr hoch ist
da in den Ländern in denen die Impfquote
sehr hoch ist diese Länder sind auch
besser durch die Pandemie gekommen so
und deswegen muss man sagen ist eine
hohe repräsentieren hier ein
katastrophal Information stand das
stimmt hinten und vorne nicht schauen
sich die infektionssterblichkeit an wir
haben hier Informationsstand stimmt also
sie spekulieren
ich kann Ihnen das ganz genau belegen
begegnen die diese Beschwerden haben auf
der Weser wahrscheinlich bei jedem
Impfstoff vor dass Menschen das
vertragen oder auch nicht vertragen
einfach Medikament wir haben einen
Versuch am lebendigen Objektiv Prozent
der Bevölkerung gut vertragen
100 Flügen 10 tödlich enden würden würde
die Fluggesellschaft sofort ein
Flugverbot bekommen 10% wär schon
wahnsinnig viel das einzige was wir
nicht wissen ist wie hoch der Anteil der
Erkrankung und der Todesfälle ist an der
gesamtseite Impfungen und kommen Sie mir
nicht mit China weil China hat eine
betrugspolitik Betrieben vom ersten Tag
an die haben nach einem Jahr eine
who-delegation an den Ort gelassen oder
das Virus entstanden sein könnte nach
einem Jahr oder eine andere Debatte nein
das kennen aber die sehen doch im Moment
würden sich doch entschuldigen
da brauche ich nur in die Bild-Zeitung
zu gucken oder in die Welt bitte bitte
ganz klar drin und das andere berichten
dass die Chinesen im Moment riesige
Probleme haben weil die Bevölkerung zu
wenig geimpft nein ich muss mir doch
sagen es gab zwei Länder mit einer
unheimlich hohen Impfquote Portugal und
Israel und in beiden hat trotzdem
Impfquote das Virus gnadenlos
zugeschlagen es gibt dazwischen deine
verbindliche Korrelation nicht so stark
wie in Ländern und
Bulgarien stehen gut da aber ist es das
Grundproblem ist doch dass die
Wissenschaft überhaupt keine Chance
hatte die ihm wird die aufgepocht haben
sie nicht gehört worden ausgegrenzt
worden wir haben eine
infektionssterblichkeit festgestellt ja
die einer mittleren Krippe entspricht
sogar für die eigentlich ist die bedroht
dieses Virus nur die älteren ja wenn man
den Fokus auf dem wenn man das wenn man
wenn man den Fokus auf die Altersheim ja
dann hätte man darüber reden können aber
es war vollkommen irrsinnig die unter
70-jährigen soeben von vollkommen sind
sie haben da überhaupt
dieses Zahl die sind gegen 0 bei den
jungen Menschen und die in diese
risiko-impfung sind sogar Kinder
gestorben angucken Stück laut RKI alle
schwer vorerkrankt wollen sie mich jetzt
ja veräppeln was was reden sie für
Unsinn aber
informiert
oder dass sie irgendwie allen
unterstellen sie reden Unsinn nur weil
sie anderer Meinung sind als sie
deswegen
hoffentlich nicht tun das ist das
Problem
Mediziner Verbände sich auch alles Leute
die sich nicht empfehlen nämlich die
Impfungen dringend die Impfung weil die
sagen da verhindert man sehr viele
schwere Fälle und man verhindert häufig
auch Todesfälle deswegen empfehlen die
Ärzteverbände die Impfung also die
intensiv Lobby da muss noch mal
getrennte Übersprechen und die falschen
Meldungen die gemacht haben Tatsache ist
und das hat er sparen beauftragt das
wäre das die Bundesregierung ab April 21
dass wir eine historische Unterbelegung
auf den intensiver Abteilung hatten das
ist Fakt steht Ihnen auf dem
Bundesgesundheitsministerium auf der
Homepage sparen verursacht veranlasst da
steht das drin sie hatten Unterbelegung
Seite die ganze corona-zeit haben wir
Unterbelegung in den Krankenhäusern wo
ist denn da bitteschön die Katastrophe
also diese Impfung wurde gepusht von
Anfang an und es ist ein wirklich ein
Menschheitsverbrechen was da gerade
passiert das muss es gestoppt werden
also ist sterben ganz viele weil die
geimpft sind also wollen sie das ganze
erzählen natürlich also wir müssen
unterscheiden
zwischen Lockdown und ebenfalls muss
noch genau ermittelt werden woher die
Übersterblichkeit kommt sie mir ja haben
im letzten Dezember hatten wir 19%
Übersterblichkeit im Vergleich zu den
Vorjahren ein bisschen rauskriegen ob es
der Lockdown war oder die Impfung aber
die waren Signale dass die Impfung einen
sehr großen Teil davon ausmachen doch da
wie kann man denn jetzt die die
Zulassung noch weiterlaufen lassen es
ist ein komplettes aus
das ist jetzt passiert wirklich zahlen
Fetischismus wenn wir uns eine halbe
Stunde zurückziehen
vor paar Wochen noch in einer Sendung
des ZDF gesagt wir haben ein Experiment
gemacht mit 4 Milliarden Probanden und
es gab gar keine Nebenwirkungen von der
haben sie glaube ich noch die Zahlen
nicht verlangt aber das ist etwas
anderes mit Zahlen kann man sehr sehr
viel haben noch die Überspannung
bezahlen also das kann sagen alle
Ärzteverbände Intensivmediziner
Virologen Leute die sich auskennen
die Impfung wird empfohlen und die
Impfung hat schwere Verläufe verhindern
haben 900.000 Leute unterschrieben und
professionalso aus medizinischen Berufen
ja von Harvard und Stampfer die haben
von Anfang an gewarnt sie wurden sogar
bei Twitter gesperrt ja also das ist
eine ist ein unglaubliches skandina es
gibt genügend Leute die ernsthaft und
genau davor gewarnt haben und sie wurden
diskriminiert der persönlichen ist
gekündigt worden in Wien ja also wenn
sie sagen alle Wissenschaftler haben sie
offensichtlich nur die auf die gehört
was sagen sie dann zu China im Moment da
sind die Leute ja zum Großteil nicht
geimpft oder ganz schwach geimpft wollen
Sie jetzt von mir wissen was keine
Ahnung glauben sie irgendeiner Zahl die
aus China kommt nach Wurstmarkt
zu schauen
Sie Ihre Informationen aus der Zeitung
okay alles klar Information ich äußere
mich nicht zur Kinder weil ich Angst
meine vielleicht hat man in ihrer Partei
von dem Beruf noch nichts gehört nicht
wahr aber
versuchen
wirklich unterirdisch und das wissen sie
von ihnen gesagt sie sind komplimen Sie
bitte noch mal wir haben jahrelang in
einem gaune wie Dieter dem nebenan
gesessen und hat eine nicht ausgemacht
lassen sie uns alle mal beim Thema
bleiben sie haben gesagt alle Impfstoffe
die zugelassen sind Herr Bruder sind
wirksam und okay das haben sie gesagt am
23 April beim Parteitag 2021 auch wenn
uns klar geworden ist im Zuge dieser
Sendung dass sie nicht der Meinung sind
von Dr Frank findet trotzdem bei Ihnen
einen Umdenken statt in dem Sinne dass
sie sagen ich würde die Aussage so nicht
mehr treffen und ich finde wir müssen
uns das genauer anschauen ich habe jetzt
ehrlich gesagt nicht mitgekriegt was die
zitiert
ich sag's noch einmal nein
alle im Stoffe die zugelassen sind sind
wirksam und okay
würden Sie diesen Satz heute so sagen
oder würden Sie eine haben Sie eine
andere Sensibilität
also nach 40 Jahren Pandemie habe ich
natürlich eine andere Sensibilität auch
noch mal irgendwie zu überprüfen was
waren richtige Maßnahmen was waren
vielleicht überzogene Maßnahmen der
ganzen Auseinandersetzung um den
Lockdown welche Maßnahmen
Schulschließungen Kita Schließung was
glaube ich wirklich viel gravierendere
gesellschaftliche Folgen hatte als die
Frage der Impfstoffe ich sag das noch
mal ich glaube ich glaube sofort dass es
Menschen gibt denen das Impfen überhaupt
nicht bekommen ist und die
Nebenwirkungen haben sowie andere
Menschen bei Medikamenten Nebenwirkungen
haben die vielleicht auch noch gar nicht
bekannt waren und die trotzdem
auftauchen können weil da ist jeder
Mensch anders aber das so zu
generalisieren wie es Herr Dr Frank
macht da habe ich meine Zweifel und er
hat mir noch keinen Beweis vorgelegt
dass das wirklich eine massenhaftes
Phänomen ist der deswegen mit zwei
bezweifle ich nicht einen einzigen
Einzelfall und daraus eine Strategie zu
machen dass das Impfen an sich schädlich
ist das finde ich politisch falsch weil
das Impfen war tatsächlich der Weg um
aus dem Lockdown rauszukommen aus
fatalen Schulschließungen und
kita-schließungen rauszukommen um wieder
ein gesellschaftliches Leben in dieser
Situation der Pandemie zu organisieren
das geht auch übrigens für viele andere
Krankheiten also viele Krankheiten in
der Menschheitsgeschichte wurden nur
besiegt und bekämpften
alle Impfungen
konfrontiert deswegen bin ich halt auch
so emotional dass ich würde es
eigentlich gar nicht erzählen ich würde
das gar nicht als irgendwo bezeichnen
davon abgesehen aber ist der Punkt ist
der und das ist jetzt wirklich sehr
wichtig nicht ich muss beweisen dass das
stimmt was ich sagen sondern die
zulassen Behörden müssen beweisen dass
die dass der Verdacht nicht stimmt und
da gibt's ein gesetzlichen Auftrag das
Paulchen tut hat
gesetzlich festgeschrieben
Infektionsschutzgesetz die Aufgabe die
Daten der Krankenkassen abzurufen und
hat zu analysieren es verweigert diesen
Auftrag seit zwei Jahren und die Leute
zulassen
aber sie geht damit das Risiko ein ja
dass die Menschen diesen riesigen
ausgesetzt werden und deswegen frage ich
sie auch als Parlamentarier was machen
sie damit dass paul Ehrlich Institut
endlich seinem gesetzlichen Auftrag
nachkommt ja wo ist ihre Initiative
wollen sie das alles der AFD überlassen
ja ich meine wo sind sie also eigentlich
ja irgendwie so ein Pappkameraden auf
den es gar nicht gibt also ich habe
selber ich will ja gerade darauf
eingehen es wird ein bisschen schwierig
wenn Sie nach einem Wort sofort wieder
kommen sie so können sie aber in der
Demokratie auch nicht diskutieren wenn
sie sowieso der Meinung sind sie haben
nur recht und ihre Meinung anders okay
ich sie sollten wir schon in der
Demokratie überlassen wie ich meine
Sätze anfangen das lasse ich mir nicht
von anderen vorschreiben
also natürlich müssen wir uns damit
beschäftigen gibt es irgendwo im Schäden
gibt es irgendwo auch Fälle aus dem man
Schluss unserem ziehen muss und ich bin
auch sehr dafür dass wir ernst nehmen
dass es immer noch auf viele in
Deutschland gibt die Sorgen haben die
auch das Impfen ablehnen und die Ängste
haben so und darauf muss man eingehen
und auch mit den Instituten wir haben ja
im Moment auch eine Diskussion eher
bezogen auf das
weit-koch-institut ob das nicht mehr so
stark auch anders Gesundheitsministerium
angedockt sein soll sondern eher auch
eine eigenständige Behörde sein soll das
finde ich seinen Ansatz den wir
insgesamt gerade im Gesundheitsbereich
vorantreiben sollten und das geht dann
natürlich auch für andere Institute also
insofern bin ich auch sehr dafür und sag
jetzt nicht man soll diese Sorgen nicht
ernst nehmen
ist dass man sagt man hat irgendwo
vielleicht Fälle bei denen auch das
Impfen dann schädlich war umgekehrt
haben wir aber ganz viele Fälle bei
denen das Impfen hilfreich war und
daraus jetzt sogar Schluss zufolgern
naja impfen ist grundsätzlich schädlich
und hilft nicht um das Coronavirus
ja genau aber jetzt noch mal ich habe
damit sehr gute Erfahrungen gemacht bei
mir gab es auch keine Nebenwirkungen und
ich bin bisher auch ganz gut durch die
Pandemie gekommen und glaube auch dass
das Impfen da geholfen hat so wie auch
irgendwie in anderen genau
ist
wieso es gibt auch aber es gibt doch
insgesamt viele Analysen ich habe ja
eben auch Ärzteverbände und so genannt
die sagen mit dem Impfen kann man sehr
sehr viele Fälle verändern die auf der
Intensivstation landen oder die dann
sterben das natürlich weiß man im
Einzelfall nie genau was wäre wenn ja
Humbug weil sie eben den Einzelfall
nicht überprüfen können
insgesamt aber deswegen werden doch
klinische Studien gemacht und äh Studien
mit vielen Probanden und daraus haben
sie dann irgendwann eine ganz
Deutschland
nein nein nein nein nein nein nein nein
nein nein was anderes
die Geschichte der Einführung des
medikam Mensch am Anfang sollte es die
Infektion verhindern dann sollte es die
Übertragung verhindern dann wurden
weitere Kriterien angeführt die alle
nicht gestimmt haben es gab die R den
R-Wert dann gab es die Parole Flecken
the curve wenn es nicht weiterging für
den Fachleuten leider auch ihren
Kollegen immer etwas ein und die letzte
rückzugsposition die wir jetzt haben die
aus statistisch und
experimentell nicht Nachweis nachweisbar
ist dass es schwere Verläufe verhindert
das kann man überhaupt nicht feststellen
weil bei demjenigen der Schere Verlauf
verhindert wurde müsste man
logischerweise das ganze noch mal im
Gang setzen ohne die Impfung ich kenne
Leute die viermal geimpft wurden schwer
krank sind sie haben vielleicht Glück
gehabt andere nicht
und Wissenschaft
die argumentieren diesen Satz alle
Wissenschaftler
sondern Wissenschaftler primäre
teegeschichte
im Lehrbuch drin aber der Punkt ist sie
wollen zahlen haben ja man hat immer
versucht diese Zahlen zu verhindern zum
Beispiel diese imbissurfstute von Herrn
Professor mattis in von DAK Charité als
erstes war die einzige einigermaßen
brauchbare prospektive Studie dazu der
hat rausgekriegt jeder jeder 140 hat
schwere Nebenwirkung da wurde dann wurde
er diskriminiert und von der Charity
Mund totgestellt ich meine rechnen Sie
mal die Zahlen hoch das immer bei etwa
800.000 schweren Nebenwirkung und ich
glaube das auch und der Punkt ist
einfach der was was sie gerade gesagt
haben sie
ignorieren den gesetzesverstoßen zu tun
die ignorieren ist die die machen
einfach die die machen ihren Job nicht
obwohl das gesetzlich vorgeschrieben ist
und es wird von Parlament einfach nicht
themaisiert sie lachen ich habe die mir
die Debatte angeschaut vom 60 Dezember
sie lachen denjenigen ins Gesicht die
auf diesen Gesetzesbruch hinweisen und
damit sage ich noch mal lachen sie
meinen Impfung ins Gesicht nicht und das
ist nicht viel aber gar nicht gelacht
durch ich habe auch kein impfen weil ich
habe genau die Abgeordneten mir
angeschaut diese Witze gerissen haben
darüber hat das über die Zahlen von
Herrn Lausen die nämlich sehr wohl war
dieses sind ja sie haben einfach ihn als
als
datenzahler fest also so gesagt ich weiß
nicht was war der hat immer der Sorge
hat glaube
Festival Pandemie ist noch immer nicht
vorbei das hat der Kanzler jetzt gesagt
echt auf ihre Lieblingsveranstaltung